wow I'll tell you what that sets up an
MMA fight for sure yeah for sure if they
want to do it and make more money that
makes it very interesting that sets up
an MMA fight for sure you probably give
that fight to Jake yeah me too
yeah I'd imagine Jake impressive man
yeah that was impressive that was
impressive and Diaz poured it on man he
did and a lot of people this idea is
going to get blown out yeah man you
survived yeah any any to DS credit I'd
watch him fight again yeah yeah they
were both impressive that knockdown's
the most significant moment in the fight
for sure
for sure that was a big shot that was a
bad knockdown
I mean Diaz won some rounds for sure but
I think Jake won it yep 98 91 yep
98.91's a little ridiculous
yeah it's a little but the right one so
there's not an issue with it but
the right guy won